ich rufe nun auf den Zusatzpunkt 3
Beratung des Antrags der Fraktion der
cdu/csu mit dem Titel keine
erbschaftssteuererhöhung durch die
Hintertür
für die Aussprache
wurde eine Dauer von 68 Minuten
vereinbart
die Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Baas
ruft jetzt diesen Zusatzpunkt 3 auf
Stichwort Erbschaftssteuer es gibt ein
Jahressteuergesetz 2022 das wurde am 14
Oktober hier in diesem Haus zum ersten
Mal debattiert es enthält einige Punkte
die noch einmal im Nachgang
diskussionswürdig waren und auch ein
bisschen durch die Medien gegen nämlich
die Art und Weise auch die bestimmte
Freibeträge definiert wurden das Ganze
also jetzt noch mal auf Antrag der
Unionsfraktion hier in der Debatte wir
haben einen gewissen Wechsel der
Fachpolitiker
von
Energie und Wirtschaftsbereich hin zu
den Finanz- und Haushaltspolitikern und
jetzt das erste Wort an die
Unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
den Antrag eingebracht hat
frau Präsidentin werde Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mit unserem Antrag keine
erbschaftssteuererhöhung durch die
Hintertür wollen wir sicherstellen dass
auch zukünftig eine vernünftige Balance
bei der Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer
vorhanden ist denn mit der im
Jahressteuergesetz der Ampel
vorgesehenen Veränderungen beim
Bewertungsgesetz stehen wir vor einer
empfindlichen Erhöhung bei der Erbschaft
und Schenkungssteuer bei Wohnungen
Häusern und Grundstücke
die steuerliche Neubewertung wird dazu
führen dass die seit 2009 unverändert
gebliebenen Freibeträge bei der
erbschafts-
[Musik]
eine gerechte Erbschaftssteuer ist in
einer sozialen Marktwirtschaft ein ganz
wesentlicher Faktor und dabei ist es von
großer Bedeutung dass wir hier Maß und
Mitte halten und nicht umsonst ist ja im
Grundgesetz in Artikel 14 nicht nur das
Eigentum garantiert sondern auch die
Vermögensnachfolge auch der
generationentransfer über das Erbrecht
und die Möglichkeit
die Möglichkeit bereits voll
versteuertes Vermögen
innerhalb einer Familie auf die nächste
Generation übertragen zu können ist ein
ganz wesentlicher Treibstoff in unserer
sozialen Marktwirtschaft das treibt die
soziale Marktwirtschaft an denn wer baut
als privater ein Haus wenn er später das
gleiche nicht in der Familie weitergeben
kann
wir brauchen also eine
Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer die
Leistung nicht erstickt wir peppeln den
Wohnungsbau mit viel Steuergeld in
vielen Bereichen weil wir zusätzlichen
Wohnraum brauchen und wenn dann die
Erben wegen überhöhter Besteuerung zum
Verkauf des erschaffenen Wohnraums
genötigt werden dann stimmt doch
irgendetwas nicht das muss man doch mal
insgesamt sehen auch das ist
Nachhaltigkeit wenn wir Menschen die
Möglichkeit nehmen das teilweise über
Generationen hinweg aufgebaute
erschaffene auf die nächste Generation
zu übertragen dann nehmen wir Anreize
für wirtschaftliche Betätigung in einer
sozialen Marktwirtschaft muss sich
Leistung lohnen und wenn der Staat den
Menschen zu viel weg besteuert dann
erstickt er die Leistungsbereitschaft
dann erstickt er den Leistungswillen der
Menschen und das gilt bei Ertragsteuern
genauso wie bei der Erbschaft was er
eine substanzsteuer ist
viele Menschen arbeiten sie sparen sie
gründen sie erhalten Vermögen gerade um
es später ihren Kindern weiter zu
übergeben und ich glaube wir werden in
dieser Debatte ja noch einiges hören und
da weiß ich jetzt schon da wird nachher
wieder die mehr vom Erbe als
leistungsloses Einkommen können
diese mehr ist in den meisten Fällen
falsch unser Steuerrecht beruht auf dem
Grundsatz der Besteuerung nach der
individuellen Leistungsfähigkeit und die
Weitergabe von bereits versteuerten
Vermögen innerhalb einer Familie
verändert die wirtschaftliche
Leistungsfähigkeit dieser Familie
überhaupt nicht
die Weitergabe von aufgebauten
Vermögenswerten an die nächste
Generation ist kein leistungsloses
Einkommen es ist in dieser Familie kein
windfall Profit denn man weg besteuern
müsste sondern es ist Erhaltung von
leistungsanreizen
und dieser Geschichte von diesem
leistungslosen Einkommen des mag
vielleicht gelten im Bereich der
Steuerklasse 3 bei Erbschaften also
beispielsweise bei einer Erbschaft vom
Großcousin aus den USA oder dem
Vermächtnis von der guten Freundin und
in diesen Fällen da haben wir ja ganz
bewusst einen ganz niedrigen Freibetrag
und wir besteuern in diesen Fällen ja
auch des Erbe mit einem Steuersatz von
bis zu 50% und das ist völlig in Ordnung
in diesem Bereich wir sprechen aber hier
gerade bei unserem Antrag über den aller
engsten Familienkreises geht um
Ehepartner es geht um Kinder es geht um
die Enkel und in diesem engen Bereich in
diesem engen Bereich der Familie da hat
sich der Staat so weit als möglich
herauszuhalten und das gilt auch für den
Fiskus
und wenn die Ampel jetzt durch das mit
dem ftp-geführten Finanzministerium die
steuerliche Bewertung von Immobilien
erhöht dann muss zum Schutz dieses engen
Familienverbundes gleichzeitig die
Freibeträge entsprechend angehoben
werden
seit über einem Jahrzehnt wurden die
Freibeträge nicht mehr angepasst und
wenn jetzt vom Finanzminister zusätzlich
an der bewertungsschraube gedreht wird
dann ist es zwingend dass man diesem
Antrag von uns folgt und die
entsprechenden Freibeträge anhebt wir
fordern neben der Möglichkeit zur
Regionalisierung die Anhebung der
Freibeträge bei Ehegatten von 500.000
auf
825.000 für Kinder von 400.000 auf
600.000 von Enkel von 200 auf 300.000
und bei Eltern und Großeltern auf
165.000 bei allen anderen Personen
halten wir eine moderate Anpassung von
20 auf 33.000 Euro für richtig noch mal
uns geht es vor allem um die Familie uns
geht es darum dass das Elternhaus in
einer Familie weiterhin steuerfrei
vererbt werden kann das gebietet im
übrigen auch schon der Respekt vor der
Leistung der ausbaugeneration und diese
Aufbaugeneration ist wichtig und sie
reden immer von Respekt zeigen Sie ihnen
hier weil das eben so sieht der sollte
unserem Antrag heute auch zustimmen
vielen Dank
Olaf Gutting zur Eröffnung dieser
Debatte auf Antrag der Unionsfraktion im
Hintergrund steht eine Vorgabe des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts und auch
Immobilien beide Erbschaftssteuer nach
dem aktuellen Verkehrswert angesetzt
werden müssen es hat natürlich eine
erhebliche immobiliepreis
immobilienpreisveränderungen der letzten
Jahren gegeben jetzt im Düsseldorf für
die SPD-Fraktion
ich bin ja eigentlich froh dass die
Union heute den Antrag eingebracht hat
weil es wäre wirklich schade gewesen
wenn ich morgen meine drei mütige Rede
zum Jahre Steuergesetz hätte
missbrauchen müssen um dazu zu sprechen
weil die letzte öffentliche
Berichterstattung dazu war so breit dass
es auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
Aufklärungsarbeit verdient und da bin
ich froh dass ich heute 7 Minuten von
ihnen bekomme um dazu dann noch mal
Stellung zu nehmen was was beschließen
wir wirklich ich will erstmal ein
bisschen Aufklärungsarbeit leisten weil
die aus meiner Sicht auch eben in der
Rede ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen ist
die Grundlage dessen was wir momentan
tun ist ein Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes von 2006 das
hat festgestellt dass Vermögenswerte in
der Beschreibung von Erbschaften gleich
behandelt werden müssen das ist momentan
nicht der Fall deswegen verändern wir
jetzt auch die
immobilienbewertungsverordnung das ist
übrigens kein Thema was den
Bundesfinanzminister zu verdanken ist
oder wo man eben keine Schuld zuschieben
kann eingeleitet hat dieses Verfahren
der bundesinnenministerin von der CSU
2019 das ist glaube ich noch mal ganz
wichtig zu betonen einfach auch um die
sachliche Richtigstellung hier
vorzunehmen
dazu kommt sie vermitteln immer wieder
den Eindruck dass wir die
Erbschaftssteuer selbst erhöhen würden
das tun sie indem sie ein bisschen damit
kokientieren indem sie Dinge auch
miteinander vermischen ich will noch mal
ganz klar sagen wir erhöhen die
Erbschaftssteuer nicht wir verändern die
Bewertungskriterien passen sie an das an
was das Bundesverfassungsgericht
vorgeschrieben hat wir setzen geltendes
Recht um das ist seriöse und gebotene
Regierungspolitik und um ehrlich zu sein
dass auch ziemlich alternativlos das
zeigt auch dass ihr eigener CSU
mindestens vor zwei Jahren bereits
eingeleitet hat
es ist dennoch wichtig auch noch mal zu
betonen was es heute bereits für
Privilegien und Freibeträge gibt weil
die wurden eben auch ein bisschen
ausgespart das ist glaube ich noch mal
ganz gut die auch zu betonen die
Freibeträge sind für Partner 500.000 €,
also eine halbe Million 400.000 € für
Kinder 200.000 € für Enkel dazu kommt
gerade bei Wohnmobilen wichtig dass wir
natürlich auch keine Grunderwerbsteuer
verlangen das ist Element der
Wettbewerbsvorteil gegenüber all
denjenigen die nicht erben können die
müssen nämlich Grunderwerbsteuer zahlen
das ist häufig vergessen noch mal ganz
wichtiger Punkt und ein Punkt der eben
auch nicht erwähnt worden ist weil immer
mit Omas Häuschen argumentiert wird
die Vermietung die Übertragung selbst
genutzter Immobilien bis 200
Quadratmeter Wohnfläche ist sowieso
steuerfrei das Immobilie die Immobilie
kann 2,5 Millionen Euro kosten ich kann
wenn ich da selber einziehen die
steuerfrei übernehmen wo ist da ihre
Gerechtigkeitslücke das ist bereits
gerecht und das wird ausreichend vom
Gesetz berücksichtigt
und jetzt kommen wir zum Thema
Vermietung weil das ja auch erwähnt wird
bereits da gilt auch ein verminderter
Wertansatz 90% und die Möglichkeit der
Stundungen über zehn Jahre also man kann
wirklich nicht davon sprechen dass hier
ein übergriffiges Finanzamt agiert das
hier irgendwie ungerecht Gelder wegnimmt
sondern es gibt eine ganze Reihe von
Privilegien die schon genutzt werden und
ich will über die
Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten gar nicht
sprechen alle zehn Jahre Schenkung
vornehmen versteckt Optionen
betrieblichen Vermögen Stiftung dass ich
da noch mal informieren will kann auch
gerne an die Finanzausschuss Mitglieder
der CDU CSU sich wenden weil die sind im
hauptberuflich noch als Steuerberater
oder Fachanwälte für erbschaftsrecht
tätig also da wird man sicherlich gute
Beratung bekommen
[Applaus]
sie schüren Ängste um Interessen
durchzusetzen und das tun sie ganz
bewusst niemand hier will Omas Häuschen
wegnehmen wir schützen das hart
arbeitete Wohneigentum wir schützen
klein und mittlere vermögen wir schützen
Omas Häuschen wir wollen aber auch
Gerechtigkeit und Chancengleichheit
dafür steht die Sozialdemokratie
und ich möchte da auch noch mal auf das
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgericht von
2016 abheben und das darf ich kurz
zitieren die Erbschaftssteuer ist ein
Beitrag zur Herstellung sozialer
Chancengleichheit die sich in der freien
Ordnung nicht von selbst herstellt die
Erbschaftssteuer wird der Gefahr
entgegen dass durch eine zunehmende
Ungleichverteilung von Mitteln die
Chancen auf gesellschaftliche wie
politische Teilhabe auseinanderdriften
und sich so letztlich Einfluss und Macht
zunehmend unabhängig von individueller
Leistung verfestigen und dann Herkunft
gebunden sind das ist die Kern äh
Aufgabe der Erbschaftssteuer und
deswegen ist sie auch weiterhin gerecht
und muss auch von uns aufrecht halten
werden und sogar eigentlich noch
verschärft werden dazu komme ich aber
gleich und jetzt komme ich zum zum
Vergleich zur Diskussion zum Bürgergeld
hat nämlich Friedrich Merz sie haben
gesagt zum Bürgergeld der Grundsatz dass
man in Deutschland mit Arbeit mehr Geld
verdient als ohne muss ohne wenn und
aber auch heute und für die Zukunft
gelten unabhängig davon dass das beim
Bürger Geld stimmt und dass wir das auch
immer wieder betont haben dass es
richtig ist was sagen sie in deinem
Kontext zu Erbschaftssteuer dazu ich
habe nicht dafür gearbeitet wenn ich von
meinen Eltern Haus Erbe dafür haben
meine Eltern gearbeitet für mich ist das
leistungsloses Einkommen und deswegen
ist es auch gerecht dass der Staat das
besteuert
und es lohnt sich auch noch mal in der
Gesamtbetrachtung die Zahlen aufzuführen
wir haben 2021 in Deutschland rund 400
Milliarden Euro Erbschaften und
Schenkung zu verzeichnen davon werden
rund 11 Milliarden Euro Steuern
festgesetzt das ist ein
durchschnittlicher Steuersatz von 2,7 %
im Verhältnis zum Gesamtvolumen im
Vergleich das mittlere Arbeitseinkommen
ungefähr 50.000 € brutto im Jahr wird im
Durchschnitt mit 23% besteuert wir
können also wirklich nicht davon reden
dass Erbschaften deutlich stärker oder
gar ungerecht besteuert werden wer hat
arbeitet in dieser Gesellschaft der muss
Steuern zahlen aber nicht die reichen
Erben die müssen keine Steuern und die
obersten zehn Prozent erhalten übrigens
auch die Hälfte aller Erbschaften es ist
jetzt nicht so dass es ein breites
gesellschaftliches Phänomen ist über die
Hälfte bekommt gar keine Erbschaften die
obersten zehn Prozent erhalten die
Hälfte der Erbschaften und Schenkung das
ist glaube ich auch noch mal ganz
wichtig zu betonen um das ins Verhältnis
zu setzen und Herren ich freue mich dass
Sie der Debatte beiwohnen ich habe mir
die Mühe gemacht noch mal zu suchen nach
Daten die sie bisher zu dem Thema
geäußert haben und da gibt es ja nicht
so viel zu finden aber einen doch ganz
interessantes Zitat was glaube ich den
meisten gar nicht bekannt ist sie haben
im Vorwege der Bundestagswahl als
Experte des Team Laschet für Wirtschaft
und Finanzen folgenden Satz gesagt oder
folgende beiden Sätze in der Folge einer
Reihe von verfassungsgerichtsurteilen
muss das sogenannte Familien in
gebrauchsvermögen im erbschaftsstollen
steuerfrei bleiben ich habe das eben
erwähnt es bleibt auch steuerfrei das
selbstgenutzte Wohneigentum ist
steuerfrei das ist das
familiengebrauchsvermögen wenn das
darüber hinausgehende Vermögen mit
niedrigen Steuersätzen breiter besteuert
werden soll kann man darüber reden das
ist ja ganz interessant das ist unter
der Headline übrigens tituliert worden
März offen für erbschaftssteuerung und
heute kommen Sie mit dem Antrag um die
Ecke ich muss sagen das ist so eine
interessante Wandlung die sie auch hier
vorgenommen haben
aus unserer Sicht ist hier also eine
ganzheitliche Reform notwendig ganz ganz
wichtig wir müssen endlich die
Privilegien der betrieblichen Vermögen
entziehen wir müssen endlich dafür
sorgen dass die die wirklich Kohle haben
in dieser Gesellschaft ordentlich
besteuert werden wir müssen die
schenkungsfristen verändern und dann
können wir auch darüber reden ob man
Freibeträge anhebt ansonsten ist das mit
uns nicht zu machen wir leben diesen
Antrag ab herzlichen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
soweit Tim flüssendorf für die
SPD-Fraktion ist übrigens eben Ausschuss
für Finanzen wie viele der Redner die
wir jetzt hier in diesen
Tagesordnungspunkt 68 Minuten angesetzt
hören werden jetzt als nächster Redner
Albrecht Glaser afd-fraktion Frau
Präsident meine Damen und Herren die
Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer war immer
prekär sie knüpft nicht an einer
erwerbswirtschaftliche Tätigkeit oder an
den Konsum an sondern greift in die
vermögensubstanz ein sie stellt eine
legalisierte Enteignung da
da das Sterben typischerweise für
Menschen eine schmerzliche Angelegenheit
ist und das Schenken als ethisch positiv
und sozial wertvoll angesehen wird
erstaunt immer wieder dass diese
Ereignisse bzw Verhaltensweisen zum
Anlass genommen werden für eine extrem
invasive fiskalische Intervention
zum Beispiel im Jahre 1997 das oder
Hochwasser viele persönliche berufliche
Existenzen waren bedroht es gab große
Hilfsbereitschaft etwa gegenüber
Handwerkern die gerade auf die Füße
gekommen waren
Verwandte Freunde und Berufskollegen
haben sich ökonomisch engagiert
wenn durch solche Initiativen etwa für
die Neuausstattung einer Werkstatt
Gegenstände im Wert von 300.000 Euro
schenkweise zugewendet wurden wurde eine
solche Aktion mit 84.000 Euro
Schenkungssteuer belegt sofort zu
entrichten durch den
bei der Erbschaftssteuer kommt die
Besonderheit des Eingriffs in den
Familienverband hinzu und das Problem
der Zerschlagung von Unternehmen und
zwar speziell im Mittelstand weil die
Steuersätze von 20 30 oder 40% bezogen
auf die Verkehrswerte solcher
Unternehmen solche Steuerlasten nicht
getragen werden können dieses Problem
beschäftigt das Verfassungsgericht der
Kollege hat eine Entscheidung gelandet
es gibt aber mehrere dazu und die
Gesetzgebung seit vielen Jahren
unerlässig allein zwischen 2008 und
heute hat es beim Bewertungsgesetz und
beim Erbschaft schenkungsgesetz
jeweils über 100 Änderungen gegeben so
wird hier herumgewusstert
in der Zeit behandelten Jahr
Steuergesetz wird erneut das
Bewertungsgesetz unter anderem in den §
787 und 88 geändert es geht dabei um
Parameter der Bewertung bebauter
Grundstücke die beabsichtigte Änderung
bedeutet Werterhöhung gegenüber dem
bisherigen Bewertungsverfahren
dies geschieht vor dem Hintergrund seit
Jahren explodierender Immobilienpreise
und betrifft Millionen von Bürgern diese
Verbesserung des Rechtes ist daher
abzulegen
die Verteuerung von Eigentumswohnungen
betrug in den letzten zehn Jahren 130%.
der Hauspreisindex ist von 82 im Jahr
2008 auf 154 im Jahr 21 gestiegen also
um 90 Prozent
erstaunlicherweise gibt es darauf keine
Reaktion der Bundesregierung und der
Ampelkoalition die Wertverhältnisse
haben sich seit über 10 Jahren als die
heutigen Freibeträge und Wertgrenzen
festgelegt wurden so drastisch verändert
das vergleichbar zu Einkommensteuer das
Festhalten an nominalen Werten der
Vergangenheit eine Verfälschung des
seinerzeitigen gesetzgeberischen willens
ist meine Damen und Herren es müssen
also nicht nur die Freibeträge sondern
auch die Werte der progressiven
Steuertarife in den drei Steuerklassen
im Paragraph 19 Erbschaft
Schenkungssteuer angepasst werden und
dies aus verfassungsrechtlichen Gründen
meine Damen und Herren
erstaunlicherweise nimmt die 10 der
CDU-Antrag nur die Freibeträge in den
Blick was ich nicht verstehe stattdessen
ist eine sofortige Anpassung der
Wertgrenzen aus denen sich die
tarifbelastung ergibt und der Höhe der
Freibeträge vorzunehmen das eine tun und
das andere auch und wir brauchen zumal
bei den obwaldenen inflationsstypen eine
automatische Indexierung wie wir sie
auch in der Einkommensteuer anschreiben
und sogar seit ein paar Jahren
einigermaßen ordentlich hinbekommen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
mehr Rechtsstaat braucht das Land
herzlichen Dank
so war der Beitrag von Albrecht Glaser
für die afd-fraktion mit Kid im
Finanzausschuss wir werden jetzt gleich
erleben die Rednerin der grünen Fraktion
Katharina Berg der wird ungefähr noch
mal die Argumentation
haben spannend wird dann der Redebeitrag
von der FDP-Fraktion in der Ampel ist
das nämlich nicht ganz homogen
verehrte Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und
Bürger Sie hier im Raum wissen alle dass
mir Konstruktivität am Herzen liegt aber
dieser Antrag ist leider nicht
konstruktiv anstatt sich Gedanken
darüber zu machen wie wir die Krise in
diesem Land angehen und den Unternehmen
und Menschen helfen können dies wirklich
dringend brauchen kommt die CDU CSU
jetzt sind einem Antrag zur Erhöhung der
Freibeträge bei Erbschaften das erkennt
die aktuelle Problematik in unserem Land
überhaupt nicht an und das auch
verfassungsrechtlich einen sagen wir mal
vorsichtig mutiger move zum aktuellen
Kontext es ist eine die Grundfesten
unserer Industrie und unsere sozialen
wertversprechens erschütternde Krise und
Inflation Unternehmen leiden unter den
hohen Energiepreisen die von Ihnen als
CDU maßgeblich mit verursachte
klumpenabhängigkeit von russischen Gas
in Höhe von 55 Prozent für zu
dramatischen Konsequenzen für unsere
Wirtschaft wir als moderne
wirtschaftskoalition machen dieses Land
nun mit einer Diversifikation Strategie
in nie dagewesenem Tempo und Dynamik
zukunftsfest
und zu den Menschen etwa 40 Prozent der
Menschen in unserem Land haben praktisch
kein eigenes Vermögen die Inflation
trifft die untere Mitte am härtesten
noch dazu jedes fünfte Kind lebt in
Kinderarmut auch das ist alles leider
ihr politisches Erbe mit dem wir jetzt
umgehen müssen und noch viel mehr
Menschen etwa 70 Prozent Erben überhaupt
gar nicht ihr Antrag bezieht sich ganz
klar auf die Menschen die in dieser
Krise stärkere Schultern haben und die
in einer ganz großen Mehrzahl auch sehr
solidarisch diese starken Schultern
gerne für unsere Gesellschaft tragen und
dafür bin ich sehr dankbar
die Haushaltsmittel die wir aktuell
einsetzen und einsetzen müssen die
müssen wir fokussieren auf die
Unternehmen und auf die Menschen die es
wirklich brauchen das sind nicht die 30
Prozent Erben denn sondern das sind
genau die vielen Millionen Menschen und
Unternehmen die nicht wissen wie sie in
ihre Energierechnung bezahlen können und
ich kann ganz klar sagen dass wir das in
der Regierung mit nie dagewesen und so
zielgenauen entlastungspaketen wie
möglich mit Preis bremsen und
strategischer Energiepolitik vor allem
im Bereich der freiheitsenergien beherzt
in die Tat umsetzen
stattdessen versuchen Sie hier heute
eine stellvertreterdebatte aufzumachen
um abzulenken dass sie eben keinen guten
Plan für Deutschland haben sie wollen
sich als Freunde von Omas Häuschen
aufspielen dabei sind Erbschaften und
Schenkungen in Deutschland sowie auch
das Vermögen an sich sehr ungleich und
bei wenigen verteilt die meisten Omas
haben überhaupt keinen Häuschen wie
gesagt etwa 70% der Menschen Erben gar
nicht und zwei dritte der Erbschaften
Schenkung gehen nur an die 20 Prozent
vermögensten Menschen in Deutschland
Erbinnen in Deutschland gehören dort
einer DIW-Studie meist ohnehin zu den
privilegiertesten vor allem in
Westdeutschland mit ohnehin schon hohem
Vermögen und hohem Einkommen
in meiner Rede zur Ungleichverteilung in
Deutschland habe ich in der vorletzten
Sitzungswoche einen mir sehr wichtigen
Punkt gemacht Vermögen also schlicht
gesagt Geld ist vor allem ein Mittel zur
Erfüllung von Bedürfnissen und dem
Endeffekt für Freiheit und Teilhabe
Möglichkeit und zur Erinnerung diese
Freiheiten sind leider sehr ungleich
verteilt das Vermögens der erst ein
Prozent der Erwachsenen besitzt etwa 45%
des Gesamtvermögens und damit sogar
etwas mehr als 90% der gesamten
Erwachsenen in unserem Land und nur
Vermögen kann vererbt werden Erbschaften
und Schenkungen sind leider ein großer
Treiber für die Zementierung der hohen
Ungleichheit in Deutschland und mir ist
beim Thema Erben vor allem der
Leistungsgedanke wichtig inzwischen wird
das meiste private Vermögen durch
Erbschaften oder Schenkungen generiert
und nicht durch die eigene Arbeit
effektiv muss man aber auf das völlig
leistungslose Erben mit ca 2%
durchschnittlich ca 20 mal weniger
Steuern und Abgaben zahlen als auch die
eigene Hände Arbeit das ist einfach
krachend ungerecht für das
Leistungsversprechen und die Möglichkeit
sich selbst etwas aufzubauen ohne in die
entsprechenden Familien hineingeboren zu
sein in diesem Land natürlich kann man
auch ohne über Lohnnebenkosten reden
aber der ganz viel größere Bedarf
besteht doch darin die wir mit der
Zementierung von sehr ungerechten
Vermögensverhältnissen in Deutschland
und mit der Erosion des
Leistungsversprechens und damit auch der
Demokratie und der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft umgehen die durch das
nahezu kostenfreie Erben leider auch mit
verursacht wird
wir müssen bei der Erbschaftssteuer wie
beim Thema Ungleichheit die Debatte aus
der tabu-ecke in eine positive
gestaltungsdiskussion für unser Land
bringen und zum verfassungsrechtlichen
die Wertanpassung die wir im
Jahressteuergesetz vornehmen sind
verfassungsmäßig vorgegeben aber auf
eine Art haben sie ja völlig Recht als
Union sehr wahrscheinlich besteht auch
verfassungsrechtlich noch weitere
Reformbedarf um die Erbschaftssteuer im
Einklang mit unserem Grundgesetz zu
halten aber wenn man das ändern würde
dann müsste man die Erbschaftssteuer
eben grundsätzlich angehen zuletzt 2014
erklärte das Bundesverfassungsgericht
nach 2006 aufs Neue dass das
Erbschaftssteuerrecht verfassungswidrig
sei der Grund eben das Ausmaß und die
ausgestalt der Steuerbefreiungen waren
mit dem Grundrecht der steuerlichen
belastungsungleichheit nicht vereinbar
und wir alle hier wissen dass das was
2016 dann als Reform beschlossen wurde
er ein Reform Versuch war der die
eigentlich bemängelten Probleme eben
nicht tatsächlich angeboten hat Beispiel
verschonungsbedarfsprüfung die bedeutet
im Endeffekt das besonders reiche
Erbinnen im Zweifel mit nicht allzu
komplizierten Mitteln im Endeffekt dann
überhaupt nichts bezahlen müssen die vom
Verfassungsgericht bemängelten Probleme
sind augenscheinlich nicht wirklich
gelöst und auch im Immobilienbereich
gibt es eine fast schon skurrile
Ausnahme für die Verschonung von
Wohnimmobilien die normalerweise nicht
als steuerbefreites Betriebsvermögen
zählen können wenn 300 oder mehr
Wohneinheiten hingegen vererbt werden
handelt es sich um ein
Wohnungsunternehmen was dann auch von
der Steuer befreit ist diese Regel hat
der Bundesfinanzhof bereits bemängelt
ihr Antrag Liebe Union ist leider ein
billiger Versuch zu spalten und Ängste
zu führen dieses Land hält aber zusammen
darauf bin ich stolz wenn es ihnen
ernsthaft und mehr Leistungs- und
Chancengerechtigkeit geht bin ich aber
sofort bereit mit Ihnen grundlegend über
eine Reform der Erbschaftsteuer zu
sprechen vielen Dank
Katharina Beck ist die finanzpolitische
Sprecherin der Bündnis grünen Fraktion
die Erbschaftssteuer hat nach ihrer
Position auch die Aufgabe
Gerechtigkeit abzubilden in dieser
Gesellschaft Christian Görke Sprecher
für Finanzpolitik der Linken Fraktion
da haben sie als Union ja einen Antrag
hervorgebracht der er richtig Sturm im
Wasserglas hier hervorruft denn der
andere lautet ja keine
erbschaftssteuererhöhung durch die
Hintertür aber die Realität ist bisher
hatten wir nur
erbschaftssteuersenkungen durch die
Hintertür und diese Tür meine Damen und
Herren wird jetzt geschlossen weil mit
dem Gesetz Immobilien und Grundstücke
endlich im aktuellen Marktwert bei der
Erbschaftssteuer berücksichtigt werden
heißt während Zukunft erbt muss dann
auch den aktuellen Marktwerk für seine
geerbte Immobilie versteuern abzüglich
natürlich dieser auch durchaus
beachtenswerten Freibeträge nur fair
meine Damen und Herren das ist nur fair
schließlich werden Aktien Kunstgemälde
Ersparnisse auch zum Marktwerk hier
versteuert und es ist glaube ich auch
nur gerecht denn betroffen ist kaum Oma
kleinhäuschen das zur Eigennutzung hier
benutzt wird sondern es geht doch
wirklich das wissen wir doch alle die
luxusboden und um die Erbschaften von
gleich mehreren Immobilien die jetzt
adressiert werden und liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der Union manchmal
denke ich sie nutzen gerade
oberkleinhäuschen als Abwehr Schild
damit sie die Interessen von Multi
Multimillionären Erben so ein bisschen
argumentativ hier verstecken können und
wenn Sie meine Damen und Herren von der
Union wenn Sie diese
erbschaftssteuergerechter machen wollen
dann schaffen sie doch die Schlupflöcher
und Privilegien ab wie zum Beispiel
ein geerbter Bestand von 300 Wohnungen
der Betrieb zum Betriebsvermögen
klassifiziert wird damit fast quasi
steuerfach übergeht und da ging die
Armen von zwei Wohnungen ordentlich
zahlt dann hat das nichts mit Maß und
Mitte zu tun dann ist das er für die die
dann zahlen eher eine dummensteuer denn
und da kommt noch hinzu ihr größer das
Erbe dass du niedriger der Steuersatz
2019 meine Damen und Herren
2019 haben in Deutschland allein 40
Multimillionären insgesamt ein Vermögen
von 9,4 Milliarden Euro geerbt an
Steuern zahlten sie
172 Millionen das macht ein Schnitt mit
einem mini-steuersatz von 2% aus während
bei den kleinen und niedrigen
Erbschaften in Deutschland im Schnitt 9%
zu zahlen waren und diese
Ungerechtigkeit steht im Mittelpunkt und
an diese Ungerechtigkeit müssen wir ran
und da wo ist denn da meine Damen und
Herren von der Union ihr Vorschlag sie
reden Tag ein Tag aus hier vom
Leistungsprinzip und gönnen den Menschen
beim Bürgergeld nicht mal das schwarze
unter den Fingernägel Gängen die mit
Sanktionen aber wenn die Millionen und
Milliarden hier Steuer werden nahezu
steuerfrei durchlaufen ja dann habe ich
den Eindruck Herr Pudding denn sind sie
auf beiden Augen nicht sehend
und das hat mit harter Maloche kaum
etwas zu tun und wenn sie noch ein
Beispiel brauchen dann nehmen wir doch
mal Susanne klappen die gerade aus der
Schule kam und mit einmal zur BMW
Großaktionären wurde wissen Sie meine
Damen und Herren von der Union das hat
das ist ein leistungsloses
Grundeinkommen meine Damen und Herren
Herz das ist ein leistungsloses
Grundeinkommen was hier hervorgerufen
wird und zum Schluss Herr putting ich
schätze sie sehr aber es war natürlich
heute ein bisschen schwierig für sie
denn die CDU und damals der
Innenminister Horst Seehofer hat ja
diese neuen Bewertungsregeln für
Immobilien unter Umgehung und der
Umgebung des Deutschen Bundestages als
Verordnung auf dem Weg gebracht und
insofern habe ich den Eindruck sie
agieren momentan nach dem Motto
was schert mich mein Geschwätz von
gestern wir lehnen
Christian Görke sehr vom Fach jetzt
Sprecher für Finanzpolitik zwischen 2014
und 2019 war er landesfinanzminister im
Bundesland im Brandenburg jetzt ganz
spannend zu hören Claudia Raffel Höschen
von der FDP-Fraktion der FDP hat ein
bisschen dezidiert andere Position als
die anderen ampelpartner
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen oft waren im
vergangenen Wochen zu hören dass die
Erbschaftsteuer erhöht würde das ist
natürlich totaler Quatsch eine
Erbschaftsbesteuerung von Immobilien ist
nicht geplant
Gesetzes über das Jahressteuergesetz
beruht auf einer
2021 umgesetzten Anpassung der
Immobilienwert ermittlungsverordnung die
damals insbesondere von der Union
vorangetrieben wurde sie war notwendig
da das Bundesverfassungsgericht zweimal
erst 2006 und dann erneut 2018 anmahnte
dass alles was vererbt wird
gleichermaßen zu bewerten ist egal ob es
ein Sparbuch ist ein Aktiendepot oder
eben auch eine Immobilie
nun sind in den vergangenen Jahren die
Immobilienpreise kontinuierlich und
deutlich angestiegen der
Immobilienbesitzer und spätere Erblasser
hat also auch tatsächlich ein höheres
Vermögen so dass auch ein höherer
Nachlass vererbt wird die angestrebte
Gerechtigkeit in der Immobilienbewertung
und späteren Erbschaftsbesteuerung ist
aber schon lange nicht mehr gegeben nach
dem bisherigen bewertungsprinzipien kann
es vorkommen dass der Verkehrswert
deutlich unterschritten wird hier
entsteht also eine Grauzone die laut
Verfassungsgericht nun geschlossen
werden muss durch die angestrebte
Neuregelung stellen wir nun sicher dass
die
grundbesitzbewertung zu einer
realistischeren Wert Ermittlung führt
diese Anpassung dienen dazu die realen
Wertverhältnisse am Immobilienmarkt
abzubilden
unangetastet bleibt zum Beispiel die
Möglichkeit für den Erben ein
niedrigeren Verkehrswert durch ein
Gutachten zu erbringen auch bleibt es
bei dem bisherigen Regelungen dass ein
Familienheim im Falle des Todes
steuerfrei auf den Ehepartner oder die
Kinder vererbt werden kann denn klar ist
wer sich etwas aufbaut für seine Familie
vorsorgt dessen Erben dürfen dafür nicht
bestraft werden
aus diesem Grund liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union ist es wieder
gerecht noch fair solche Grauzonen nun
einfach zu dulden denn es ist weder
verfassungskonform noch bürokratisch
sinnvoll außerdem war es auch ihnen in
16 Jahren Regierungszeit durchaus
bekannt dass die Immobilienpreise massiv
ist ansteigen dass die aktuellen
bewertungsregelung verfassungsrechtlich
fragwürdig sind und eine neue Regelung
unausweichlich ist das hätte auf dem
damaligen baumminister sehr hoch aus
ihren Reihen bekannt sein müssen die nun
plötzlich in ihrem Antrag formulierte
Forderungen nach einer Erhöhung der
Freibeträge wirkt also wenig glaubwürdig
sie hätten es bis vor gut einem Jahr
selbst umsetzen können haben die
Freibeträge aber seit 2009 nicht
angetastet
das sind 13 Jahre wir regieren nun seit
einem Jahr und schließen nun erstmal die
von ihnen hinterlassenen
Steuerschlupflöcher
aber und das will ich in aller
Deutlichkeit sagen es war unser
Fraktionsvorsitzender Christian Dörr der
kürzlich genau diese Debatte um die
Erhöhung der Freibeträge öffentlich
angestoßen hat auch koalitionsintern
diskutieren wir das und werden unsere
Liberalen Überzeugung selbstbewusst in
der Debatte einfließen lassen das
verspreche ich Ihnen
so wie bei der kalten Progression im
Einkommen Steuerrecht sollte auch die
Erbschaftssteuer an die Inflation
angepasst werden um reale
Steuererhöhungen die nicht
parlamentarisch legitimiert sind zu
vermeiden
wenn man nun eine Erhöhung der
Freibeträge anstrebt was wir durchaus
unterstützen müssen wir uns fragen ob
wir ob das nicht zu kurz greift müssten
wir nicht auch über ein vollständig
indexierten Steuertarif in allen
erbschaftssteuerstufen sprechen denn nur
so kann der inflationären Erhöhung der
realen Besteuerung entgegengewirkt
werden
wichtig ganz wichtig ist uns dass eine
solch komplexe Entscheidung nicht übers
Knie gebrochen wird in der Koalition
stehen wir für konstruktive und vor
allem legitime Lösung und nicht für
Schnellschüsse und daher lehnen wir
Ihren Antrag ab und ganz nebenbei
bemerkt eine Erhöhung der Freibeträge
führt auf der anderen Seite natürlich in
den Ländern zu Steuer Mindereinnahmen da
wir hier
wie auch in anderen Bereichen keinerlei
Kompromissbereitschaft im Bundesrat
sehen wäre ein Gesetzesentwurf nicht
mehr als heiße Luft und eine reine
schaufensterdebatte zeigen sie doch
liebe cdu/csu ein wirklichen
lösungshüllen auch im Bundesrat indem
sie die Mehrheit haben wir hoffen in
Zukunft auf eine ehrliche
Oppositionsarbeit vielen Dank
da war noch eine kleine Shelter Richtung
Union drin aber durchaus in der Sache
auch noch mal der Hinweis dass ich die
FDP dem Gedanken öffnen kann einen
indexierte Anpassung von
Erbschaftssteuer vorzunehmen mal schauen
wie wir die nächste Position hören von
der Union Sebastian
erster Fakt die Ampel hat einen
Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt der unzweiflaft
in sehr vielen Fällen zu einer deutlich
höheren Erbschaft und Schenkungsteuer
führen wird
zweiter Fakt die Ampel erhöht dabei
nicht die Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer
direkt sondern sie ändert die
steuerlichen Bewertungsmaßstäbe dadurch
werden Häuser und Wohnungen steuerlich
wesentlich wertvoller eingeschätzt bei
einem unveränderten Steuersatz kommt es
hierzu zu einer deutlichen Erhöhung der
Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen und den
Ballungsräumen
im Ballungsräumen kann es sogar bei der
Berechnung zu einer Verfünffachung der
Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer kommen
wenn man die Freibeträge nicht anpasst
und die neuen
Bewertungsmaßstäbe liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen weil es angesprochen worden ist
mögen verfassungsrechtlich geboten sein
aber es steht nirgends es steht nirgends
dass es verfassungsrechtlich in diesem
Jahr umgesetzt werden muss und es ist
auch wenn Sie diesen dieses Argument
einfügen dass die Häuser und Wohnungen
im Preis gewonnen haben und der zugelegt
haben dann müssen sie zwingend auch das
Argument gelten lassen die Freibeträge
in gleichen Maße zu erhöhen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und das tun sie
nicht auch ziemlich von der FDP auch
wenn Sie hier in der Rede als
oppositionsrede sozusagen vortragen
Dritter Fakt der Gesetzentwurf im Jahre
Steuergesetz 2022 ist nicht aus dem
damaligen Innenministerium gekommen das
ist die glatte Unwahrheit und verdreht
alle Tatsachen die haben es auch heute
wieder behauptet nein der Gesetzentwurf
kommt aus dem FDP-geführten
Finanzministerium und der kommt von
Christian Lindner Christian Lindner und
die FDP greifen in die Taschen der Erben
das ist die Wahrheit liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und das muss hier auch mal
gesagt werden
der Gesetzentwurf kommt von einer Partei
die im Wahlkampf noch gesagt hat
übrigens zurecht
steuererhöhungen sind Sabotage am
Aufschwung und sie kommt von einer
Partei deren Chef vor vier Tagen lieber
Herr Lindner vor vier Tagen am 28
November beim Zentralverband des
Deutschen Handwerks gesagt haben und ich
zitiere wir sind in der
Vorweihnachtszeit fürchtet euch nicht
mit dieser Koalition und mit diesen
Finanzminister wird es keine
Steuererhöhungen geben sie zwingt keiner
von dieser Haltung Abstand zu nehmen
lieber Kollege Lindner wenn Sie eine
Erhöhung der Immobilienbewertung
durchsetzen müssen dann erhöhen Sie
bitte auch die Freibeträge in
gleichermaßen deswegen helfen wir heute
mit unserem Antrag
sie machen die Menschen in unserem Land
bewusst wieder
ärmer und sie nehmen den Menschen in
unserem Land ihr hart erspartes Geld
einfach weg Kollege Bremen und man kann
ja bitte bestatten sie eine Frage oder
Bemerkung des Kollegen Schmidt
selbstverständlich gerne
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Bremen vielen
Dank Frau Präsidentin für das gestatten
der Zwischenfrage
erleben Sie sagen wir würden die
Menschen in Deutschland
ärmer machen
jetzt kann ja jetzt das Argument
verstehen dass durch die steigende
Inflationsrate tatsächlich
die Wertsteigerungen in der Form
bisschen knapper ankommen als von uns
erwartet oder erwünscht nichts desto
weniger müsste man sich doch jetzt auch
mal die Wertentwicklung anschauen die
Immobilien genommen haben im Vergleich
zur Inflationsrate ist ihnen klar dass
sie
Inflationsrate in den letzten Jahren
immer so um hier mal Daumen zwischen
einem halben und zwei Prozent war jetzt
den aktuellen Jahr bei 8% allein die
Immobilienpreise sich aber nur in zehn
Jahren allein um 65% gesteigert haben
ist es da nicht nur fair und richtig
diese enormen Wertsteigerungen der
Immobilien auch entsprechend moderat zu
besteuern wie es ja mit der
Erbschaftssteuer denn der Fall ist
Liebe Kollege Schmidt fair und richtig
wäre wenn man diese 65% Wertsteigerung
die sie erwähnen auch im Freibetrag
abbilden würde weil ich sage Ihnen eins
wenn man mal nehmen wir mal nehmen wir
mal unseren Großraum bei uns in Nürnberg
ein normales kleines Reihenhaus ist
inzwischen bei einem Wert von 750 bis
800.000 Euro und das soll vielleicht
vererbt werden von einer Generation die
hart gearbeitet hat die keinen Urlaub
gemacht hat die sich das abgespart hat
weil es der nächsten Generation besser
gehen soll und die vererben des jetzt an
die nächste Generation und sagen die
Familie soll da rein aber vielleicht
muss sie beruflich auch wieder umziehen
und dann greifen Sie in die Tasche und
nehmen es weg deshalb ersparte von den
Menschen übrigens sind auch
wahrscheinlich ihre Wähler wo man das
Geld wegnimmt insofern sehe ich es nicht
so wie sie ich glaube wenn Sie eine
Erhöhung der Immobilienwerte abbilden
wollen im Gesetz dann müssen Sie auch
zwingen sind eine Erhöhung der
Freibeträge vornehmen ansonsten machen
sie die Menschen einfach ärmer
liebe Kollegen
die Frage ist warum das nicht im Gesetz
umgesetzt ist obwohls der Finanzminister
obwohl es der Finanzminister auch
angekündigt hat die Freibeträge zu
erhöhen und warum die FDP hat er auch
gerade gesagt sie ist dafür warum ist es
nicht umgesetzt
ja gerne lassen sie auch eine Frage oder
Bemerkung aus der SPD-Fraktion
ja vielen Dank dass Sie die Frage
zulassen weil es geht darum dass sie
Behauptungen jetzt aufgestellt haben
eine Rechnung aufgemacht haben die doch
noch mal zu hinterfragen sind übrigens
ich komme aus Bayern ich komme aus der
Nähe von München und ich weiß dass du
die Wertstellung sehr hoch sind nehmen
wir gesetzt an es gibt ein Reihenhaus
wie sie gesagt haben ein reineckhaus das
ist in den letzten zehn Jahren hat sich
da Wert verdoppelt das war vielleicht
bei 500 000 €, wenn es gekauft wurde
jetzt eine Million 1,2 Millionen Euro
wert jetzt haben wir gesetzt die
Situation die Eltern sterben es kommt
zum Erbfall es gibt zwei Kinder es gibt
erstens mal Herr Bremer sie unerwähnt
lassen schon die Möglichkeit über
Schenkungen alle zehn Jahre pro Kind und
Elternteil
400.000 Euro steuerfrei weiterzugeben
das wäre bei einem innerhalb von einem
von einem Jahr das komplette Wert eines
Gottes weiter verschenkt ohne das
steueranfällt und genauso fällt das
ganze auch an beim Erbschaftsfall bei
zwei Kindern und zwei Eltern das heißt
also Herr Brehm wenn ich Ihre Rechnung
richtig verstehe und sie ihr Haus in
Nürnberg benennen dass das mit den
heutigen Freibeträgen bei zwei Kindern
schon vollständig steuerfrei übergeht
mal bei der Tatsache wenn es selbst
bewohnt wird das bis zu 200 Quadratmeter
diese Wohnfläche vollkommen steuerfrei
übergeht wenn es selbst bewohnt wird wo
bitteschön ist ihr Skandal denn sie hier
hochziehen wollen den es gar nicht gibt
schauen sie erst Rudi ihre Rechnung geht
ja nicht auf
wenn Sie das ist eine
sozialdemokratische Rechnung der
Umverteilung wenn Sie Ihr Haus in
München annehmen und zwei Kinder erben
dann werden sie das Haus verkaufen
müssen um die Erbschaftssteuer zu
bezahlen und was passiert doch das ist
der Fakt das ist der Fakt ich kann Ihnen
aus der Realität berichten in der sie
leider nicht immer zu Hause sind dass
das der Fakt ist lieber Kollege und ich
sage Ihnen sie fordern jetzt die
Menschen auf sie fordern jetzt die
Menschen auf ihr Erspartes schon jetzt
an die Kinder zu übertragen aber
überlegen Sie mal manche wollen ihr
spart ist auch ein Stück zurückbehalten
weil wenn sie in Pflege kommen oder ein
ein bei der Rente Geld brauchen dann
können Sie jetzt noch nicht vererben
weil dann das Häuschen eben schon auf
der nächsten Generation lass der
deswegen ist Ihre Rechnung falsch und
beachten Sie mal auch eines diese zehn
Jahre bei 200 Quadratmetern da muss man
ja zehn Jahre Personen in der heutigen
Arbeitswelt kann das passieren dass man
vielleicht von München nach Hamburg geht
Frau Kollegin Beck und dann ist die
Erbschaftssteuer zu zahlen und dann muss
man eben den Umzug bezahlen und die
Erbschaftssteuer und muss das Haus
verkaufen das ist die Realität in
Deutschland und die können sie nicht
leugnen sie können sie nicht leugnen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Frage
ist ja die Frage ist ja wenn der
Finanzminister des gefördert hat die
Freibeträge anzupassen ist es dann
Absicht dass es jetzt nicht im Gesetz
ist oder ist es rot-grüne Umverteilung
wir haben ja in der letzten
Sitzungswoche auch über Vermögensabgabe
überlastenausgleich gesprochen den sie
befürwortet haben als es sie wollen erst
50 Prozent des Vermögens wegnehmen und
dann auch noch mit Erbschaftssteuer
besteuern das ist die eigentliche Plan
sie wollen dass die Menschen in unserem
Land kein Vermögen mehr haben sie
sprechen im Wahlkampf von Respekt sie
sprechen im Wahlkampf von Respekt
die Menschen die hart arbeiten die früh
aufstehen die sich was ersparen die
nicht in den Urlaub fahren diejenigen
die was für die nächste Generation
schaffen wollen den nehmen Sie das
Vermögen Weg das ist respektlos liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor den
Menschen die hart arbeiten das ist
respektlos
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
höhere Steuer wird doch dazu führen
dass Erben ihr Elternhaus verkaufen
müssen um die höhere Erbschaftssteuer zu
bezahlen
sie wird davor zu führen dass
einheimische an Investoren verkaufen
oder an gewerbliche Interessenten und
sie wird dazu führen dass es zu
drastischen Mieterhöhungen kommt damit
sind sie die mieterhöhungspartei in
Deutschland Nummer eins droht grün und
gelb liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
ist unsozial was da passiert
die Freibeträge liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sind seit 13 Jahren nicht
angepasst
und deswegen wenn wir die
Bewertungsmaßstäbe ansetzen dann
brauchen wir auch die Freibeträge und
wir bringen noch einen weiteren Aspekt
an der seit Jahren diskutiert wird und
richtig ist
wir wollen eine Regionalisierung der
Erbschaftssteuer prüfen weil es nämlich
auch die unterschiedlichen
Lebenswirklichkeiten in den
unterschiedlichen Bundesländern abbildet
und der Kollege Lindner sie haben gesagt
die Initiative soll von den Ländern
kommen jetzt kommt die Initiative von
den Ländern im Bundesrat dann erwarte
ich aber auch ihre Zustimmung zu diesem
Gesetz und ihre Zustimmung auch übrigens
heute es wird sich zeigen ob sie es
ernst meine liebe Frau Kollege
raffelhöschen wenn Sie hier sagen es
muss eine Erhöhung der Werte geben dann
stimmen sie jetzt unserem Antrag zu oder
sie zeigen den Menschen da draußen dass
es ihnen egal ist was sie gestern
vorgestern oder vor vier Tagen gesagt
haben liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Jahressteuergesetz morgen ist eine
Enteignung der fleißigen und eine
bewusste Verarmung der Vermögenden und
deswegen lehnen wir es abstimmen sie
heute unserem Antrag zu herzlichen Dank
der Unionsabgeordnete Sebastian Brehm
mit der CSU mit einem munteren Austausch
hier mit den Herren schrodi SPD und
Schmidt Bündnis 90 grüne die sich hier
durchaus auch
Bremen ist im echten Leben auch
Steuerberater über die Realität im
deutschen Erbschaftssteuerrecht noch
ausgetauscht haben nächste Redner
Lennart von der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist schon
grotesk also immer wenn es hier um
Änderungen bei der Erbschaftssteuer geht
wenden sie als Gegner dieser Steuer
verlässlich dieselben
Kommunikationsstrategien an der
Bevölkerung wird suggeriert dass bei
Erbschaften künftig viel höhere Steuern
anfallen das wird unser füttert mit den
allerschlimmsten dramatischsten
Horrorszenarien Enkel müssen das von Oma
geerbte Haus verkaufen weil die
Steuerlast so stark steigt
Familienbetriebe werden an Hedgefonds
verkauft damit die Erben die
Steuerzahlungen leisten können es sollen
sich möglichst viele Menschen
angesprochen für fühlen auch diejenigen
die vielleicht ein relativ normales Erbe
erwarten oder eventuell auch gar nichts
erben frei nach dem Motto Vorsicht der
Stadt will hier euch was wegnehmen
diese Strategie konnten wir zum Beispiel
2016 in voller Blüte beobachten als wir
die Erbschaftssteuer nach einer Reform
des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes das
letzte Mal reformiert haben eure
Familien wollten es gab damals nämlich
eine sehr aggressive lobby-kampagne die
bei ihnen in der Fraktion auf offene
Ohren Stoß und dann durch der gute
Reformvorschlag der das Betriebsvermögen
des Steuerprivileg beiden
Betriebsvermögen reformieren wollte am
Ende total verbessert wurde
wir haben gerade das ist ja am Ende die
große Ungerechtigkeit gerade bei den
hohen Erbschaften handelt es sich um
hohe Unternehmensanteile und wer
beispielsweise mehr als 20 Millionen
Euro erbt zahlt im Durchschnitt weniger
als zwei Prozent Erbschaftssteuer wir
hingegen weniger als 500.000 Euro erbt
das klassische Eigenheim etwa muss im
Durchschnitt über zehn Prozent
Erbschaftssteuer zahlen das ist nicht
Maß das ist nicht Mitte das ist die
eigentliche Ungerechtigkeit im
erbschaftssteuersystem
und aufgrund ihrer bekannten
Kommunikationsstrategie ist die
Erbschaftssteuer auch so unbeliebt
Befragung zeigen dass sich etwa 70%
gegen die Erbschaftssteuer aussprechen
dabei erbt die Mehrheit der Deutschen
überhaupt nicht tatsächlich Erben
weniger als 40 Prozent der Bevölkerung
in Deutschland etwas diejenigen die hart
morgens arbeiten die frühmorgens
Aufstehen die erarbeiten sich ihr
Vermögen durch Lohnarbeit und nicht
durch das Erben von höheren
Vermögenswerten und Immobilien
insgesamt ist auch die Höhe der
Erbschaften sehr ungleich verteilt zwei
Drittel aller Erbschaften gehen an die
obersten 20% der Vermögensverteilung
dabei geht es um richtig viel Geld ca
300 Milliarden Euro werden pro Jahr
vererbt dagegen ist das aufkommende
Erbschaftssteuer mit knapp 10 Milliarden
Euro eher gering und zeigt wie klein das
Problem eigentlich ist dass sie hier in
diesem Antrag so hochschreiben
es ist ja auch nicht so dass alle
Erbschaften voll versteuert werden die
Freibeträge sind angesprochen worden 500
000 € ca für Ehepartnerinnen und
Ehepartner bis zu 400.000 € für Kinder
200.000 € für Enkel auch der
selbstgenutzte Wohnraum muss von den
benannten Personengruppen überhaupt
nicht versteuert werden jedenfalls nicht
wenn der Erblasser sofort in der
Immobilie gewohnt hat und die Erben dort
mindestens 10 Jahre weiterhin wohnen
also wer das berühmte normale Haus von
Oma und Opa erbt um darin zu wohnen der
wird in Deutschland keine
Erbschaftssteuer zahlen sie machen hier
aus der Mücke einen Elefanten und das
muss man ja mal deutlich machen
was ist der Anlass dieser Debatte des
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat den Auftrag
gegeben wir müssen dafür sorgen dass bei
der Berechnung der Erbschaftssteuer der
tatsächliche Wert für Immobilien also
der Verkehrswert verwendet wird und das
ist fair und richtig und das ist bei
anderen Vermögenswerten gar nicht der
Fall ist es schon der Fall bei
Immobilienwerten ist das oder nicht und
in diesem Zusammenhang das haben sie
schon gesagt ist die Immobilienwert
Ermittlung Verordnung geändert worden
und zwar von wem vom
Bundesinnenministerium und damaliger
Innenminister war richtig Horst Seehofer
von der CSU
die geänderte Verordnung soll nun auf
den Bewertungen auf das Bewertungsgesetz
der Erbschaftssteuer übertragen werden
das ist richtig das kommt von der vom
Bundesfinanzministerium es war aber von
allen zu erwarten es war nichts
Überraschendes es war keine Hintertür
keine Tricks wie Sie es hier versuchen
zu suggerieren
nee und das liegt daran also die neue
Berechnungsgrundlage führt natürlich
dazu dass der eine Immobilie höher
bewertet werden kann das liegt daran
dass der Wert einer Immobilie steigt das
haben sie eben gut beschrieben es kann
aber auch genau gegenteilig der Fall
sein Werte für Immobilien ändern sich
unterschiedlich und wie bereits erwähnt
in den allermeisten Fällen wird aufgrund
der Freibeträge und ist selbst genutzten
Wohneigentums gar keine Erbschaftssteuer
fällig werden
und obwohl die Union diese Änderung 2021
selbst eingeleitet ist die sind sie sich
heute nicht so schade wie der diese
klassische angstkampagne zu führen
flankiert wird diese Kampagne dann
meistens von den einschlägigen
Lobbyverbänden Anwaltskanzleien Notarin
die damit natürlich fleißig mitverdienen
und dazu kann man immer die wirklich die
wildesten Rechenbeispiele die kursieren
dann zuerst in den sozialen Medien und
dann wird das dann von der Tagespresse
nachgeplappert und sie senden eigentlich
die Botschaft aus die Ampel wird
abkassieren wenn du Wohneigentum und
erbst und das soll heimlich still und
leise eingeführt werden am besten noch
während
die Uhr angehalten gestanden sie eine
Frage oder Bemerkung des Kollegen
stefinger
vielen Dank Herr Kollege vielen Dank
Frau Präsidentin dass sie die Frage
zulassen sie haben gerade Lobbyverbände
angesprochen Herr Kollege ich möchte
sich fragen wie sie denn die Aussagen
des Mietervereins München beurteilen der
hier sagt die Erbschaftssteuer führt
gerade in Ballungsräumen wie
beispielsweise München zu steigenden
Mieten
ich bin sicher dass bei diesem Thema es
nicht um ein Thema links oder rechts
geht sondern am Ende auch um ein Thema
wenn sich
Mietervereine und eigentümerverbände
hier einig sind dass die
Erbschaftssteuer auch ein mietreiber in
Ballungsräumen ist und dazu führen wird
Eigentum und ich darf mal darauf
hinweisen ich komme aus München in einer
Stadt in der 80 Prozent der
Mietwohnungen in Privateigentum sind
dass hier eine drastische Veränderung
eintreten wird bei den Mieten weil sich
nämlich viele Erben viele Erben die
Erbschaftssteuer gar nicht mehr leisten
können diese nicht bezahlen können es
sei denn sie erhöhen die Mieten
drastisch weil sie nur dann ein
Bankdarlehen bekommen oder sie verkaufen
an Investoren die dann nicht mehr neun
oder zehn Euro für den Quadratmeter
verlangen sondern 15 oder 20 Euro oder
sogar noch mehr wenn ich mir Innenstadt
lagen anschaue also von daher gerade
doch das stimmt schon und da lade ich
Sie auch herzlich gerne nach München ein
aber ich glaube das gerade die SPD die
plakatiert hat auch Respekt
Mietern im Wahlkampf hier eine
entsprechende Rolle auch zu spielen hat
und ich rate Ihnen lazi herzlich ein
vielleicht unterhalten sie sich auch mit
Münchner Oberbürgermeister SPD zu diesem
Thema denn genau diese Erbschaftssteuer
und diese Bewertungsregeln führen auch
dazu dass Mietwohnungen verkauft werden
würden Sie das bitte anerkennen weil ich
stelle jetzt fest in dieser Debatte dass
weder die Linken noch die SPD noch die
Grünen irgendetwas hier auch für
günstige Mieten machen und von daher
möchte ich sie hier um Ihre Bewertung
bitten
Herr Kollege ich gehe ja gerne darauf
ein dass sie beschreiben das ist ja das
Problem was man in Bayern hat nämlich
das überhaupt der Öffentlichkeit der
Wohnraum den man den Smart der mein
öffentlicher Hand war überhaupt fragt
privatisiert wurde das ist ja das
eigentliche Problem in der Wohnraum und
in der mietpreisdebatte ne und das ist
nicht nur ein bayerisches Problem das
ist auch ein hessisches Problem da würde
das Tafel Silber verscherbelt und ich
komme aus der Rhein-Main-Region ich weiß
sehr gut bevor sie reden ne aber ich
hatte eben angesprochen es gibt
Freibeträge gerade für die
unmittelbaren Erben für die Kinder auch
ich ähm meine Eltern haben einen Haus in
im Rhein-Main-Gebiet und meine Brüder
und ich werden es wahrscheinlich
irgendwann mal Erben aber mit diesem
Freibeträgen glaube ich wird es doch
weiterhin damit eine gute Lösung geben
und wie gesagt das Problem dass sie
eigentlich ansprechen ist das Problem
dass zu viel Wohnraum in privater Hand
ist und damals aus öffentliche Hand
natürlich verkauft wurde
ich fahre fort die Union nutzt natürlich
jetzt diese selbstinitiierte Debatte
frühere Freibeträge zu fordern ich bin
der Meinung die aktuellen Freibeträge
und Regelungen reichen aus damit in den
meisten Fällen für selbstgenutztes
Wohneigentum gar keine Erbschaftssteuer
anfällt bin eine Villa im Wert von
mehreren Millionen Euro vererbt wird da
muss dafür Erbschaftssteuer gezahlt
werden und das ist auch richtig und
wichtig so
dass sie jetzt in der Debatte oder in
dem Antrag auch fordern ist eben die
regionale Anpassung der freibeträger das
hat mich ja immer auch sehr interessiert
müsste ich schon wissen darüber
schmunzeln denn diese Forderung kam mir
aus Bayern kam von Markus Söder das
geerbte Haus am Starnberger See ist
natürlich stärker im Wert gestiegen als
beispielsweise ein Haus in der uk-markt
aber wieso für ein Haus der ein höherer
Freibetrag gelten soll wie er für einen
ebenso wertvolles Haus in Hessen in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und dann
Brandenburg das erschließt sich mir
überhaupt nicht das ist am Ende
wedermaßen noch Mitte das ist am Ende
wieder bayerische Klientelpolitik
ich rate den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
folgendes bleiben Sie cool be Fakt
fassen Sie sich in Ruhe mit den Fakten
und stellen sie am Ende fest dass sich
für Sie an meinen meisten Fällen gar
nichts ändert die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen rate ich lehnen Sie diesen
Antrag ab vielen Dank
soweit Lennart Öl
SPD-Fraktion einer der sich hier nicht
am Pool zu Wort melden wird aber wir
Twitter um 11 Uhr neun persönlich seine
Position nochmal reingegeben hat
Bundeswehr transminister Christian
Lindner den wir auch gerade im Bild
gesehen haben bei persönlichen
Freibeträgen der erbschafts- und
Schenkungssteuer besteht nach meiner
Überzeugung Handlungsbedarf als reine
ländersteuer von der der Bund nicht
profitiert sollte eine Initiative für
die Anhebung jedoch vorzugsweise aus dem
Kreis der Länder ergriffen werden
Christian Lindner und jetzt für die AFD
ein wirklich sprachlos zurück was hier
so die Kollegen der SPD verzapfen das
unglaublich dass sie wie ihr
Wirtschaftsminister von Wirtschaft und
sozialer Marktwirtschaft und Wirtschaft
und keine Ahnung haben haben Öl und der
größenordinieren reden und ihr Beitrag
wo die wunderbar gewesen wann wollen Sie
eigentlich den volkseigenen Betrieb in
Deutschland wieder installieren setzen
sich Vergleich zu den linken hin ja ihre
Gleichmacher Fantasien absondern
komme aber zum Antrag der CDU da muss
ich sagen cdsu das ist ja auch wieder
ähnlich wie beim Tarif auf Rädern sie
bewegen sich auf ein Vodafone zu aber
ich muss leider auch sagen gut gemeint
ist da nicht unbedingt gut gemacht sie
haben die Möglichkeit beim Antrag vom
Kollegen Glaser den wir einbringen
werden dass er eben auch in seiner Rede
angesprochen und dann den ganzen Sprung
zu machen denn dann vollziehen sie hier
entsprechend die richtigen Initiativen
und so weit können wir uns zu Ihrem
Vorschlag nur enthalten aber kommen wir
noch mal zu den Dingen haben Sie
eigentlich alle die schon länger hier
sitzen ihre katastrophale Geldpolitik
vergessen Null sind Negativzins da haben
sie Menschen gezielt und es ist
eigentlich auch gut so weil wir die
geringste Eigentumsquote haben in
Immobilien getrieben ja geradezu weil
man fürs Geld nichts mehr bekommen hat
und jetzt wollen Sie so zu sagen und das
ist ein Husaren Streich diese Menschen
die das getan haben übrigens kleiner
Anmerkung die Zahlen auch Steuern die
haben das aus zu versteuern Einkommen
gemacht wenn es nicht gerade die Leute
sind die sie mittlerweile mit haben
laufen lassen weil sie
Transparenzregister und andere Dinge
vergessen haben diese Leute wollen sie
jetzt doppelt bestrafen meine Damen und
Herren und das ist wirklich sozialer
Klassenkampf den sie ja macht das ist
eine Neidgesellschaft aber keine
Wohlstandsgesellschaft die wir doch
brauchen um die Zukunftsaufgaben
zusammen hier zu bewältigen meine Damen
und Herren
nehmen wir das aber mal in einem
Beispiel sie reden hier mal so
großspurig 8 Millionen ja das ist gemein
und so weiter ein Beispiel aus dem
Münchner Merkur vom November wenn Sie
also Erbe einer Immobilie in München
Hirn die Spitzen sie die Ohren von 8
Millionen sind dann wie gesagt ist das
schon mal erst mal wenn Sie den den
Erblasser sehen aus sozusagen
versteuertem Einkommen jetzt kommt
folgendes dieser 8 Millionen klingt viel
aber die Wohnung von diesem Vermieter
die werden sozial vermietet was bedeutet
das also es klang hier in dem man muss
ja sagen der Kurzintervention schon an
das heißt der wird wenn er erben will
und muss die natürlich entsprechend
mieten erhöhen oder er muss Kredite
aufnehmen und dann wird er auch die
Mieten übernehmen weiteres Beispiel für
die lernen und willigen der SPD nehmen
wir mal eine Wertsteigerung an die ist
angegeben von VDP immobilienpreisindex
von 80% seit 2010 hätte also 2010 eine
Ehegatte eine Immobilien wird
550.000 nach Abzug des Freibetrages
geerbt wäre in der Steuerklasse bei
dreieinhalbtausend gewesen ja in Ordnung
würde er das nach ihren Maßnahmen jetzt
machen und wir nehmen die 80 Prozent
Wertsteigerungen sind es heute 990.000
Euro und das ist auch in Ordnung so weil
die Leute in das Geld aus dem Geld
rausgegangen sind verschwaches er müsste
aber heute
73.500 Euro zahlen bzw Kredit aufnehmen
sie treiben die Menschen die
Altersvorsorge getrieben hat aus der
Immobilie schieben sie sich meine Damen
und Herren von der Fraktion der SPD sie
sind überhaupt nicht die Partei der
kleinen Männer oder Frauen was auch
immer aber sicherlich noch macht das
wissen die Leute doch schon in Bayern
sind sie doch eine 9% Partei wenn Sie
hier dann immer Bayern zitieren also
meine Damen und diese morgens stimmen
wir nicht zu wie enthalten uns bei ihrem
guten Vorschlag machen sie den ganzen
Sprung und stimmen Sie ein paar Wochen
in unserem Vorschlag zu dann haben sie
mich auch die Progression mit drin und
dann sind wir glaube ich hier auf einem
guten Weg zusammen mit dem bürgerlichen
Parteien danke
[Applaus]
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
hat nun dr Sebastian Schäfer das wollen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen es
ist schon erstaunlich mit welch einem
inhaltlich extrem dünnen Antrag die
Union hier versucht ein Süppchen für
Millionäre und ihre Erben zu kochen
von wegen
leberkäseetage für die Sie gerade als
CSU angeblich Politik machen wollen mit
diesem Antrag geht es wieder einmal nur
um die die im käferzelt Champagner
trinken
sie argumentieren dass aufgrund der
deutlich gestiegenen Immobilienpreise
jetzt auch die Freibeträge beim Schenken
und Erben entsprechend steigen müssen
dabei geht es lediglich darum dass wir
die Verfassungsmäßigkeit herstellen und
Immobilien nach ihrem tatsächlichen Wert
bemessen die Grundlage dafür hat ja
richtigerweise die groko gelegt die im
Jahr 2021 in Baurecht die Immobilienwert
ermittlungsverordnung entsprechend
angepasst hat jetzt geht es lediglich
darum diese Grundlage auch für die
steuerliche Bewertung zu übertragen
Freibeträge bei Schenkungen und
Erbschaften gelten ja gar nicht nur für
Immobilien wie sie das in ihrem Antrag
suggerieren wollen sondern für alle
Vermögenswerte davon würde der Erbe oder
Beschenkte einer Aktionärin die in den
letzten Jahren deutlich steigende
Kurswerte erleben konnte genauso
profitieren aber sie wollen ja in ihrem
Antrag zu tun als wer davon nur dass
sprichwörtliche kleine Häuschen der
Großmutter betroffen und sie wissen doch
ganz genau dass wir eine Immobilie die
nach dem Tod eines Elternteils von einem
Kind übernommen und bewohnt wird
überhaupt keine Erbschaftssteuer anfällt
zumindest wenn die Immobilie nicht
größer als 200 Quadratmeter ist
selbst wenn dieses Haus am Tegernsee
oder am Bodensee steht und drei
Millionen Euro wert ist fällt da kein
einziger Cent an erbschafts-
und selbst wenn die Immobilie größer ist
muss sie schon extrem wertvoll sein dass
der Freibetrag überschritten wird und
dann tatsächlich ein wenig
Erbschaftssteuer fällig wird bleiben wir
bei unserem Haus am Tegernsee oder am
Bodensee lassen wir es diesmal 250
Quadratmeter groß sein und gehen wir
jetzt von einem Wert von 4 Millionen
Euro aus Herr März würde sagen gehobene
Mittelschicht
wenn ein Kind dieses Haus erbt und es
nutzt werden 45.000 Euro Steuern fällig
also ungefähr ein Prozent des Werts und
wenn die Immobilie zur Entrichtung der
Steuer veräußert werden müsste dann kann
die Steuer sogar für bis zu zehn Jahre
gestundet werden ich bin mir sicher
diese Sorgen hätten viele Menschen gerne
die allermeisten Menschen Erben gar
nichts oder Beträge die nicht annähernd
an die Freibeträge heranreichen
Frau Connemann aus ihrer Fraktion
ist wirklich schamlos wenn sie in der
Presse davon spricht das Wohneigentum
jetzt für Erben zur Armutsfalle werden
können sie verhöhnt damit auch die
soziale Marktwirtschaft über die sie so
gerne in ihren Sonntagsreden sprechen
sie wissen auch ganz genau das sind
vielen Fällen bei Schenkungen oder
kettenschenkungen alle zehn Jahre um die
Freibeträge auszunutzen so gestaltet
wird dass gar keine Steuer fällig wird
wir sehen ja gerade was bei den Notaren
los ist da geht es nur um Schenkungen im
Zweifel wird durch Nießbrauch der Preis
gedrückt und die Steuer gespart
in ihrem Antrag ist ja auch die Rede von
einer Regionalisierung der Freibeträge
ich will das mal übersetzen die
Wertentwicklung der Grundstücke in
Deutschland war im vergangenen Jahrzehnt
höchst unterschiedlich Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg sind sicherlich
Bundesländer die in großen Teilen hohe
Immobilienpreise haben aber dies
rechtfertigt doch keine höheren
Freibeträge als anderswo warum sollte
jemand in Thüringen beim Erwerb von
einem hohen Barvermögen mehr Steuern
bezahlen als jemand in Stuttgart oder
München der denselben Wert in Form einer
Immobilie zum Beispiel eines Zinshauses
erwirbt mit ihrer Politik für die
champagner-etage Spalten Sie unser Land
deshalb kann ich für diesen Antrag für
diese dünne Suppe nur Ablehnungen finden
Sebastian Schiffer war das für die
Bündnis grüne Fraktion weiterhin wird
debattiert über den unionsantrag bei der
Erbschaftssteuer die Freibeträge zu
erhöhen nächster Redner jetzt Maximilian
Mordhorst für die FDP-Fraktion liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich vergessen
2014/2016/2018 diese Jahre haben alle
gemeinsam dass dort das
Bundesverfassungsgericht Urteile zur
Erbschaftssteuer gefällt hat diese Jahre
haben auch gemeinsam das sind all diesen
Jahren die Union regiert hat und dort
wenig bis gar nichts verändert wurde und
dass wir jetzt vor dieser
ärgerlichen Situation stehen und es hat
auch zur Folge Liebe Union dass sie ja
nicht nur Belastungen ihre
Regierungszeit an die Zukunft gegeben
haben zum Beispiel mit der
Energieabhängigkeit von Russland nein
sie haben es jetzt sogar geschafft eine
Belastung über ihre Regierungszeit
hinaus uns rüberzugeben indem sie aus
dem Bundesministerium des Innern und für
Heimat damals Horst Seehofer
Wertermittlungsverordnung entsprechend
geändert haben was dazu führt dass die
Werte für Immobilien an einigen Stellen
es steigen und dadurch eben nicht die
Sätze der Erbschaftssteuer steigen aber
einige doch Gefahr laufen höhere
Erbschaftssteuer zahlen zu müssen das
ist schon beeindruckend es würde mich
freuen wenn die Union wie es eigentlich
eine im Antrag steht mehr für
Entlastungen arbeitet und nicht nur
darüber redet anstattbelastungen in die
Zukunft zu verlagern und deswegen haben
wir vorgeschlagen vor dieser ärgerlichen
Situation die ich hier eingestehen dass
wir die Freibeträge erhöhen das wäre gut
und richtig gewesen und ich hätte mich
gefreut wenn wir das gemeinsam
hinbekommen hätten ich hoffe dass wir es
in Zukunft hinbekommen denn Wohneigentum
ist etwas Wichtiges und wichtiges wir
sehen an ganz vielen Stellen dass dort
wo Wohnungen in staatliche Hand sind und
es hat man auch schon am Anfang der oder
Jahre gesehen sie verfallen schlechter
werden und die Sanierung dann in der
Privatisierung gemacht werden und dann
10 15 Jahre wieder drüber zu sprechen
dass man es ja verstaatlichen müsste und
das alles so unsozial sein das ist nicht
unser Weg unser Weg ist nicht
distanzsteuern immer weiter zu erhöhen
unser Weg ist nicht vermögen immer
weiter zu schwächen nein wir müssen
Vermögen stärken und das bedeutet auch
dass wir privates Wohneigentum
unterstützen wir können bei dieser
Debatte und das hat mich an einigen
Stellen gestört nicht immer nur über die
Superreichen vielleicht in München oder
Campen auf Sylt sprechen sondern wir
müssen uns doch an der breiten Mitte der
Gesellschaft orientieren und natürlich
wird die Probleme haben wenn wir bei den
substanzsteuern immer weiter rangehen
das haben wir bei den Grundstein erlebt
bei der Grundsteuer erlebt das erleben
wir jetzt ein kleines bisschen bei der
Erbschaftssteuer und es ist Warnsignal
für uns alle und ich bin froh dass wir
das im Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten
haben es ist wahnsignal für uns alle
dass wir keine weiteren Substanz Steuern
einführen sollten keine Abgaben es
bedeutet für uns keine Vermögenssteuer
keine Vermögensabgabe dafür stehen wir
und das ist richtig so wir sollten
generell einmal darüber sprechen was
Substanzen eigentlich für Probleme
verursachen wir haben es bei der
Grundsteuer erlebte hatten wir viele
Debatten gerade in den Ländern wir leben
ist bei der Erbschaftssteuer und wir
hätten es bei der Vermögenssteuer erlebt
vielleicht ist der richtige Weg nicht
vermögen immer weiter zu reduzieren und
die Gruppen gegeneinander auszuspielen
sondern vielleicht ist der Weg an vielen
Stellen Vermögen zu fördern in
Deutschland wenn man sich nämlich
anschaut die großen Aufgaben die wir
haben die erwerben zu einem großen Teil
private Investitionen erfordern das wird
der Staat nicht alleine machen können
und wir haben kaum ein fähigen
Kapitalmarkt zumindest im
internationalen Vergleich was unsere
Wirtschaftskraft angeht bedeutet für uns
wir müssen den Kapitalmarkt Stärken
deswegen bringen wir das
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz auf den Weg
wir müssen private Investitionen
unterstützen die nicht nur von
Superreichen kommen müssen sondern es
muss auch attraktiv sein für die Mitte
der Gesellschaft für die Mittelstand und
die Mittelschicht zu investieren und
sich daraus etwas zu machen das ist eine
wichtige eine wichtige Maßgabe die wir
haben und deswegen freue ich mich wenn
wir an breiter Stelle unterstützen die
Menschen die Vermögen schaffen wollen
die sich etwas aufbauen wollen die auch
sich etwas machen wollen egal ob sie
erben sind oder nicht uns nicht nur an
den einigen wenigen montieren die hier
immer als Beispiele genannt werden das
ist nicht die große und breite Mitte der
Gesellschaft wir stehen für diese große
und breite Mitte der Gesellschaft und
werden deswegen auch für ein
angemessenes und faires Steuersystem
sorgen
das ist der Plan und bleibt das Ziel und
ausgesprochen von Maximilian Mordhorst
Mitglied im Finanzausschuss FDP-Fraktion
weiterhin noch mal für die Antragende
Fraktion Fritzlar von der wir uns
Fraktion Finanzamt Ausschuss ebenfalls
Mitglied die Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren lieber Max mortos ich frage mich
jetzt gerade ob sie dem Antrag nun
zustimmen würden das haben sie nicht
gesagt also die Argumentation war
schlüssig von dafür bedanke ich mich für
die klaren Worte und von daher stimmen
Sie wahrscheinlich entsprechend ab als
Redner der ziemlich am Ende der
Tagesordnung ansteht hat man ja einen
Vorteil dass man sich das vorher schon
mal alles anhören durfte und ich finde
das schon spannend wie da die
Argumentationslinien laufen ich muss ihn
ganz ehrlich sagen von FDP SPD und grün
sie kommen mir so ein bisschen vor ich
kenne das von zu Hause wenn ich meine
Söhne ertappe dass sie irgendwas gemacht
haben was ich nicht sehen sollte dann
reagieren die ähnlich wie sie mich
völlig hektisch planlos und auf schlecht
und das denn sie haben wo haben sie das
denn gemacht sie haben versucht oder
haben es ja sogar gemacht morgen soll es
ja beschlossen werden im
Jahressteuergesetz untergebracht dass
wir mehrere hundert Seiten geht dort
haben sie das mal hinten so ganz klein
Reich reingeschrieben damit das
möglichst nicht gesehen wird aber damit
haben Sie nicht mit uns gerechnet als
Opposition wir sehen sowas nämlich weil
wir eine aufmerksame Opposition sind
meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
schon wieder die Aufregung ich finde das
gut und es sind natürlich verschiedene
Gründe die sie so aufgeregt machen zum
einen die FDP der Kollege Bremen hat es
ja schon zitiert heute vor vier Tagen am
Montag hat Bundesminister Lindner gesagt
ich das so schön das muss man noch mal
zitieren fürchtet euch nicht mit dieser
Koalition und diesen
Bundesfinanzminister wird es keine
Steuererhöhung geben nun machen wir mal
den Faktencheck wie das so schön
neudeutsch heißt wir reden ja nicht nur
über die Steuererhöhung jetzt über die
Erbschaftssteuer das erste Steuergesetz
dieser Ampelkoalition war eine Erhöhung
der Steuern bei den Landwirten als die
portalierungssätze geändert worden sind
morgen im Jahre Steuergesetz beschließen
wir die nächste Steuererhöhung die
sogenannte übergewinn-besteuer die
Steuer die bei ihnen
energiekrisenbeitrag heißt aber
letztendlich machen Sie die nächste
Steuererhöhung wenn Sie das auf die
Europa schieben wollen Herr
Bundesfinanzminister dann frage ich mich
wieso sie dennoch am Montag so eine
Aussage treffen konnten weil sie ja
wussten dass sie auch sagen gar nicht
richtig sein können weil sie die Steuern
erhöhen auch ist egal warum sie sich
erhöht haben sie erhöhen permanent hier
steuern und stehen gegen ihr
Wahlversprechen und gegen ihre klaren
Aussagen und das werden wir immer wieder
anmerken
und man hat ja die Chance ein paar Dinge
richtig zurück Rücken richtig ist dass
es die Immobilienwerte
vermittlungsverordnung gibt die auch
übertragen werden sollte das war immer
so angelegt auf die Bewertung aber
richtig ist auch dass die entscheidenden
Parameter und das sind die Liegenschaft
Zinsen völlig frei durch das
Bundesfinanzministerium gewählt worden
sind und die sind erheblich gesenkt
worden und wenn man sich mit
Kapitalisierung auskennt führt die
Senkung von über 30% des Liegenschaft
dazu dass die Immobilienwerte um 30%
steigen das wäre nicht nötig gewesen das
hat dieses Bundesfinanzministerium
gemacht und dadurch wird es auch zu
hohen Werten kommen
und riesig ist es ist mehrfach
angesprochen worden glaube ich auch eine
reine Logik dass wenn der Wert steigt
das wäre nicht ganz zu vermeiden gewesen
das gebe ich auch zu dass man dann den
Freibetrag anheben muss damit man zum
gleichen steuerlichen Erwerb kommen muss
ansonsten ist es eine Steuererhöhung
denn Steuererhöhung ist nicht nur Tarif
sondern auch Erhöhung der
Bemessungsgrundlage meine Damen und
Herren
und es ist auch angesprochen worden wann
zuletzt die Freibeträge angepasst worden
sind es war mit der
Erbschaftssteuerreform zum
1.1.2019 und damals sind die Werte
gestiegen von 300 7000 auf 5.00 000 €
bzw bei den Kindern von 250.000 auf
400.000 Euro und wer war damals
bundesfinanzminister Peer Steinbrück das
will ich nur mal erwähnen die SPD und
die Gesetzesbegründung hat damals wer
schreien will reingeschrieben weil er
schon der Meinung war wenn Werte steigen
müssen auch die Freibeträge steigen ich
zitiere aus der Gesetzesbegründung die
Freistellung des Familien
gebrauchsvermögen orientiert sich am
Wert eines durchschnittlichen ein
Familienhauses und was damals richtig
war als heute auch richtig und von daher
müssen die Freibeträge hoch und darum
hatte Friedrich März völlig recht als er
dies vor der Wahl geäußert hat
und außerdem möchte ich mal sagen dass
es kein Geschenk des Gesetzgebers wenn
wir Freibeträge erhöhen sie erwähnen
hier alle
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteilen leider
haben sie das aus dem vom 22 juni 1995
gegessen und ich darf den Leitsatz
wärmer zitieren der Spielraum für den
steuerlichen Zugriff auf den Erwerb von
Todes wegen findet seine Grenze dort wo
die Steuerpflicht den Erwerber übermäßig
belastet und die ihm zugewandten
Vermögenswerte grundlegenden
beeinträchtigt auch diesen
Verfassungsgrundsatz müssen wir
berücksichtigen der zu Erhöhung der
Freibeträge zwingend führen müsste
also nochmal auf den Punkt gebracht wer
die Bewertung erhöht muss auch meines
Erachtens die Freibeträge erhöhen von
daher ist es völlig unverständlich dass
sie das nicht machen und die Folgen
sehen sie ja das ganze ist zurzeit ein
Konjunkturprogramm für Notare in unserem
Kanzleien der Steuerberater und
Wirtschaftsprüfer bei den Anwälten
häufen sich jetzt die Fragen weil die
Menschen nervös werden weil sie Sorge
haben zu übertragen da kommen sie immer
mit ihrem Familienheim den Park kann ich
ja sogar den paragrafenden paragraph 13
Absatz 1,4 a bis c und das ist nicht
einfach dass sie so ein Familienheim so
übertragen können Sie müssen es
mindestens 10 Jahre nach nutzen bei
Kindern ist es auch bei Schenkung nicht
zulässig nur noch beim Erwerb von Todes
Volk und die Lebenswirklichkeit ist doch
heute so selbst wenn sie es schaffen
unmittelbar in das Elternhaus zu ziehen
was wir allen zu wünschen ist kann es
auch sein dass sie innerhalb der 10
Jahren beruflich von Ort in den Ort B
ziehen müssen und dann fällt die
komplette Erbschaftssteuer rückwirkend
an das ist Kinder im System dann sollten
wir mal gemeinsam darüber nachdenken ob
wir da wenigsten pro rada-betrachtung
hinbekommen denn so funktioniert das
nämlich nicht wie sie sich das so
einfach mal letztendlich vorstellen von
daher gibt es viel zu tun und ich gucke
noch mal in die reine FDP mein guter
Kollege aus dem niedersächsischen
Landtag Christian der hat ja gesagt das
geht alles schnell und unbürokratisch da
hat er völlig recht morgen steht das
Jahressteuergesetz an entweder nehmen
Sie die Bewertungsfragen daraus oder
erhöhen die Freibeträge das wäre schnell
und unbürokratisch ganz im Sinne der
Familien in Deutschland ganz im Sinne
der Vermögenden in Deutschland die nur
ein Familienheim übertragen worden wir
haben hier nicht diskutiert über die
gesamte Erbschaftssteuer wie es hier
versucht wurde herzlichen Dank
soweit für die beantragenden
Unionsfraktion Fritz Künzler Mitglied im
Finanzausschuss er war der vorletzte
Redner letzte Rednerin wird dann sein
Frauke Heiligenstadt für die
SPD-Fraktion danach gehen wir schon in
die Schleife für das ceta-abkommen hier
in die Ratifizierung meine Kollegin
Katharina kühn wird sie dadurch dann
begleiten
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lieber Herr
Künstler sie sind nicht der letzte
Redner in der Debatte gewesen ich bin
die letzte Rednerin in der Debatte und
deswegen mache ich jetzt mal den
Faktencheck was sie und ihre Kollegen
hier gerade so schön an falsch
Behauptungen aufgestellt haben also
Faktencheck Nummer 1 sie behaupten wir
würden die Erbschaftssteuer erhöhen fakt
ist wir nehmen lediglich eine Anpassung
der Bewertung vor von Immobilien und das
dient das dient dem dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes das ist hat
uns nämlich aufgegeben Vermögen
tatsächlich gerecht zu bewerten und
keine Schlupflöcher bei der Bewertung
von Vermögen zu hinterlassen meine Damen
und Herren wir nehmen also keine
erbschaftssteuererhöhung vor sondern wir
passen das Vermögen schlicht und
ergreifen die Bewertung des Vermögens an
Faktencheck Nummer 2 sie behaupten dass
zu du dich bereits kleine Wohnhäuser
nicht mehr ohne Erbschaftssteuer vererbt
werden können richtig ist dagegen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren es
bleibt dabei ein Haus mit bis zu 200
Quadratmeter Wohnfläche kann indirektter
Linie bei Eigennutzung ohne
Erbschaftssteuer vererbt werden
unabhängig vom Wert der Immobilie also
auch dieser Faktencheck bei ihnen
durchgefallen
Faktencheck Faktencheck Nummer 3 sie
sprechen von unzähligen Erbfällen die
nun versteuert werden müssten fakt ist
nicht einmal mehr nicht einmal die
Hälfte unserer Bevölkerung erbt
überhaupt
Immobilienvermögen und selbst die
wenigen die Immobilienvermögen Erben
fallen nur zu einem ganz kleinen Anteil
unter die Erbschaftssteuer also auch
hier falsch Behauptung ich sag mal
Faktencheck
bei hart aber fair werden sie locker
durchgefallen da fragt
man warum machen sie das eigentlich nur
warum stellen Sie so viele falsch
Behauptungen auf Grund könnt ihr
vielleicht sein dass sie mit diesem
falsch Behauptung eigentlich von dem
guten Ergebnis zum Jahressteuergesetz
ablenken wollen sie machen sie machen
zum Beispiel mit diesem falsch
Behauptungen den Menschen Angst weil sie
nicht wollen dass wir vielleicht über
die gute Entwicklung bei der Homeoffice
pauschale reden oder dass wenn wir die
gute Entwicklung bei der Besteuerung der
Photovoltaik reden oder dass wir nicht
über die Erhöhung der Arbeitnehmer
pauscht das Arbeitnehmer Pausch
Betragens reden oder vielleicht auch
über die erhöhte Abschreibung für
Wohnungsbau Investition wir von der
Ampel machen Politik für die Menschen in
diesem Land und ohne den Bremsklotz
und ohne den Bremsklotz Union haben wir
in der Ampel in einem Jahr mehr
Sozialreformen durchgesetzt als in acht
Jahren großer Koalition meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und sie
machen
sie machen nicht nur falsch Behauptungen
sondern sie garnieren das ganze auch
noch mit Emotionen mit Angst indem sie
suggerieren dass Omas kleines Häuschen
nicht mehr vererbt werden kann aber
eigentlich geht es Ihnen gar nicht um
die Eigennutzung dieses Gebäudes von Oma
sondern ihnen geht es um die Menschen
die diese Wohnung und Häuser
anschließend mit den geerbten Immobilien
wieder vermieten wollen und das wird
insbesondere daran deutlich dass sie in
ihrem Antrag vorschlagen eine Erhöhung
der Fehlbeträge für Ehegatten auf 825
000 Euro für Kinder auf 660.000 €
vorzusehen und meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren Freibeträge das heißt
also eine Verschonung von der
Erbschaftssteuer das letzte Mal als wir
hier an diesem Pult über schon Vermögen
gesprochen haben ging es um das
Schonvermögen für Menschen die zukünftig
Bürgergeld bekommen sollen und ich finde
es
ich finde es ehrlich gesagt sehr
beschämt dass sie nur wenige Tage nach
der unsäglichen Debatte darüber dass für
diese Menschen ein Schonvermögen von
60.000 Euro einschließlich einer
Immobilie zu hoch sei nun für Reiche
vorschlagen die Freibeträge von 400.000
Euro auf
825.000 Euro zu erhöhen ich sag nur
Klientelpolitik für Reiche pur und und
statt
statt ihrer klientelanträge brauchen wir
eine sachliche Debatte wie wir mit der
steigenden Ungleichheit von Vermögen und
Chancen durch Erbschaften umgehen und
möglichst vielen Menschen Teilhabe
ermöglichen wenn Sie also ernsthaft
Interesse an einer sachlichen Debatte
zeigen dann können wir uns gern mit
ihren Vorschlägen auseinandersetzen
keine Zwischenfrage schon gar nicht von
der afd-fraktion aber der Antrag der
CDU-Fraktion der Antrag der CDU-Fraktion
das war heute morgen mit dem Zusatzpunkt
echter rohrkrippierer bei ihnen vielen
Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den Antrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu auf Drucksache
4674 mit dem Titel keine
erbschaftssteuererhöhung durch die
Hintertüren wer stimmt für diesen Antrag
die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
die Koalitionsfraktionen und die
Fraktion DIE LINKE wer enthält sich die
afd-fraktion der Antrag ist damit
abgelehnt